chaque semaine ce versailles les
retrouve son stand du marché préféré
j'ai mes habitudes ici parce que les
produits seront authentique
ce sont des produits qui sont en partie
bio tout comme et on les teste on a
testé à peu près tout ce qu'ils font et
à chaque fois on revient
particulièrement chez ce commerçant
petit à petit le carré à l'avion du
marché notre dame de versailles est
devenu un carré bio l'idée de suivre les
habitudes de consommation des habitants
c'est une clientèle très fidèle quand le
produit est bon et qui revient donc on a
une clientèle depuis plus d'un an et
demi
extrêmement finale dès 2011 la ville de
versailles avait essayé de mettre en
place un marché bio quartier saint louis
une idée peut-être trop avant gardiste à
l'époque mais une vraie demande
aujourd'hui la tendance nationale étant
là on a voulu vraiment étoffé l'extrême
qualité déjà du marché notre dame en
continuant à poursuivre son extension
le regroupement permet une meilleure
identification pour le client et attire
les commerçants la ville reçoit de plus
en plus de demandes pour faire partie du
carré réservé je préside une commission
quatre fois par an et on valide les
demandes en fonction de la qualité des
dossiers qui nous sont présentés
la sélection se fait également dans un
objectif de pluralité de l'offre
quinze commerçants variés sont présents
dans ce carré bio